you know what luke our friend eddie
would love this mobile yes he would come
on
[Applause]
hi eddie hi amy and luke hi i'm eddie
and i love mats
look we brought this mobile we made wow
you've had fun using maths
maths
no it was a craft activity not maths
it's craft and maths
really
how well as soon as you start talking
about balancing you're exploring weight
how heavy something is and that is maths
wow
in fact your mobile is a lot like
something i have here
these are called scales and they work in
a similar way to your mobile uh your
mobile is a dangly version of my scales
except my scales have trays on either
side where i can place things to compare
their weight oh wow can we weigh
something of course uh what can we weigh
um oh well what about uh
this wooden block
and another one ah well we have one
wooden cube and this one is what we call
a rectangular prism they're both made
from the same wood so abby do you think
they'll weigh equal amounts
i don't think so
you said they were made from the same
wood um but
this one
is smaller than the rectangular prism
so it must be heavier
what do you think let's find out
[Music]
i was right
that's right the rectangular prism is
heavier because it's twice as big as the
cube oh
i've got a question ask away luke
if the rectangular prism weighs twice as
much as the cube
does that mean that two cubes would
weigh the same as one rectangular prism
what do you think
go on luke experiment and see okay
[Music]
hooray
two cubes weigh the same as one
rectangular prism wow well done
how about this apple
how many cubes do you think would equal
the apple uh first feel the apple
now feel the wooden cube again
luke how many cubes do you think would
be equal to the apple i'm going to say
three hmm and abby how many do you think
four
what do you think
let's find out
here comes the apple
oh it's heavy it must be a really juicy
apple
i'm ready for the cubes here they come
one
two
three
hooray
three cubes are equal to one apple great
experimenter yeah that was fun
what if we were to weigh something
really heavy like an elephant or a
dinosaur
i don't think a dinosaur could fit on my
scales but i do know that the heaviest
dinosaur was called the argentinosaurus
that can be you luke
and abby you can be an elephant
and i'll be the scales jump on my
pretend scales elephant
wow she is a heavy elephant i wonder if
the argentinosaurus is as heavy jump on
the argentinosaurus is heavier than the
elephant in fact you would need 17
elephants to balance out the scales with
the argentinosaurus that's how big and
heavy they were
can you be a great big heavy dinosaur
romping and stomping around
stop stop stomp stomp stomp dinosaur
stomp stomp stomp stomp stomping in the
swamp some slump stomp stomps
in the swamp
[Music]